[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so item 5 is the HR service Thank You
counselor life so it's my pleasure to be
able to provide you with a series of
highlights from the web or support which
capture that tippity Jordan the response
means the Kubat pandemic and our
requirement to meet provision for our
way for the 12333 during this time the
response to the pandemic come our way
across has been truly remarkable with
many colleagues going above and beyond
anything we could have expected be that
through their approach to beauty volume
and through to adapting to new and very
different ways of working i were
specifically draw your attention to the
following sections of the report in
relation to sickness absence during the
immediate response to early age we saw a
marked increase in current reporting
config for duty many of these absences
were indeed linked to colleagues
themselves becoming symptomatic djokovic
self isolating due to a family member
becoming symptomatic and initially we
had
required to shield juicing the risk of
contracting the virus you will see from
the report our thickness up these levels
of now stabilized from neg and have
continued as a low level since then in
relation to air course practice our
response to the code that pandemic is
required many modifications to way
across active food for example Holloway
in which we deliver mandatory and
competency training professions has
required us to be created in order to
ensure safety and complying many of our
module can now a little bit virtually or
in a small a socially different way the
way in which we recruited had also
required is to be definitely resulting
in an introducing very very Fenske to
tap into the skills and knowledge of
friends and family our colleagues during
the Tyson we've undertaken vegetable
interviews and in the immediate
aftermath of laughter we set off and are
still operating beliefs or swab which is
supposed to move colleagues around the
business into keen and critical roles
the health and safety of our army has
been a paramount importance and our
health and safety team manager I've been
waiting to make sure that our ways these
including our schools are fixing our
buildings of phenyl radical
transformation in the last movie with
one-way system cleaning stations and the
collusion of death to ensure the
colleagues you do need or want to retain
to work challenges in safely our
approach to colleague engagements is
also being one of our top priority and I
am pleased to advise with since last
hour we have sent out daily newsletter
to colleagues
keeping them updated on announcements
news changing and all that important
staff communications you've also held an
on revenge' relations that I had affair
between directive and we intend to roll
out this bed with effect from the day of
July with a number of West walk events
for a broader range of colleagues to
ensure them the points of our comments
was head in our way across reintegration
program we've recently undertaken the
courts they're back
which 51% of colleagues responded this
has proven most helpful in informing
arming integration plan as well as
helped us to understand our colleagues
hoops and beers in the wake of pandemic
we are in the process of wading through
the minding the noise develop counsel
wired and direct reply the strategy and
in many cases there were others into
specific responses I'm also delighted to
abound to admire the music that will
really launch the celebrating success
team which provides a brain wave for
recognizing the continued support hard
weighing and true determination of our
colleagues and this has been linked by Y
values or epic Star Wars it's the you
know hundred and thirteen colonies
across the comic book is the Menomonee
phonetic star and 447 choose the P of
cards in fact chance the peers
if the colleagues to call me way of
thanking them please and colleague and
offering family for me I wish to bag the
committee to join along Tom hailey to be
engaged in weekly calls with Artie you
like the best
in order to touch base provide recommend
entirely on theme and engage until you
comment somewhere close I mean we've
also met with the chair of the barsaat
forums and astound how we can best
support our colleagues we different
cohorts men be very deadly whose meaning
means may be very different feedback
football parties it would be much
appreciated I thinking that we will
continue to operate during the lockdown
period I'm happy to take questions on
the way yeah it's really just to put on
record you know a big thank you to all
the staff who've worked so hard during
this period of crisis I think they've
done a fantastic job you know and
they've risen to be the
krytus that we face and you know really
grateful for that and i think on behalf
of the members really ensure that all
members will think the same they've done
a really good job and thanks to them
[Music]
okay can hear max re out of difficulty
or meets in that i just wanted to ask us
I've been in it can you see if there's
been any trends amongst them BM e staff
whether there's been any high rates of
sickness or anything due to cold fit we
have been trying to understand how we
can help those background in the
reintegration homes particularly male
and bearly 55 from a BM BM e background
may be more susceptible to contracting k
bit we have been working with the chairs
and i believe this they're going to be
some sort of mapping exercise looking at
the throughout the council where been
community working in the different roles
in the organization yes i think all
members realized that we're facing
unprecedented times and the challenges
are enormous
potentially enormous and HR particularly
our are going to face various problems
which twelve months ago they won't have
even been on the table I just hope that
managers throughout the organization in
order to ensure this fair reasonable and
consistent approach to the various
issues Richard Balter eyes will have
sufficient training I know it's
difficult to do training at this time
what the challenges are certainly there
could I ask through your chair that has
there been any consultation with the
trade unions regarding your your report
what's contained in your reports have
you shared it with the trade unions yeah
like I said in my update counselor will
be at the meeting when Scott's names
will be Queen and we make various
elements are weighing in to know and I
do know but obviously this is new ground
review yourself and the staff that
you've been sharing with northwest
employers and other organization master
they are etc which is good because I
think the next we all appreciate both in
the public and private sectors employer
employers and employees are going to
have differences and they're going to
have various problems which are going to
be after been met thank you
[Music]
now your thanks my question is about
sick sick leave and statistics and it's
more kind of an observation really that
I think it's going to be really
challenging to get realistic sick leave
statistics going forward because of the
the people who are working from home
I've been working from home for three
months and occasionally I've not felt
too well but not because I have not had
to go to work I'm just not called II and
sake I've just done my work on a
different day or at the weekend and that
flexible working that everybody's having
now how are we going to capture when
people are actually sick through our
communication to our colleagues come
from Thompson it is we are asking people
if they are on Facebook still a home
until that was now but they're on base
and what were all they're hoping the
value just thoughts describe to paying
back belief in this new way of working
and this new modular way of working we
expect food and our sickness levels drop
in any event because there is that
opportunity Nina we've all been there
when you in you've got something cared
or upset and you just don't feel like
you can make that journey to work but
actually give it an hour or two and you
may be able to sit at your laptop and
work so I think we are seeing some
benefits of that and that is something
that we would want to continue to see
the benefits of the renamed obviously
colleagues will be poorly animated for
me for a few days and that's fine and
we'll just asking colleagues to follow
the usual reporting lines and let us
know and then obviously with that degree
of flexibility we may see articles
levels and subside out of stabilize
incoming
just reaching for my team to update
Kovac 19 related absence which was pages
17 to 20 and a nice segue really from
ansible Thomson and we presented the
committee with a people for noting and
this is fouls an introduced approach to
dealing with colleagues who aren't able
to attend where during the crisis I'm
making the differentiation between those
who are unwilling to attend where during
the crisis and the and there is a clear
distinction of which we have set out the
criteria within the report we reviewed
this sympathetically as possible whilst
also recognizing we've developed the
papers and landed legal advice we've
also benchmarked our manager the legal
or policy and we've also worked
northwest employers in healthy machine
this approach it's not intended to be
punitive in its approach and it's very
much based on working with colleagues to
understand anxieties or conveying to
work the approaches that felt a number
of day we will take in order to ensure
the colleague feel and know that they
are returning to a safe environment and
we we are starting to hear some noise
from colleagues now who were saying yes
to the I can see that you are taking
every step possible to to ensure that my
return to where the 51 so I'm not
expecting with chat to use this position
and points there for us individually to
the one half entertained comments are
for committee
[Music]
Thank You chair and thank you for the
report I think it is quite comprehensive
and I think it's a necessary report I
think as long as we're seen and we
actually do take every measure that we
possibly can to ensure the safety of our
workforce in returning to work I think
it's a reasonable recommendation that's
been made and for that reason I think
also you've done a lot of research I
think around the Local Government
Association and employed local employees
and paid casts and you know the legal
team as well so I think you've gone
through a lot of processes and I think
it isn't the last resort that would take
action and I think the house that's
something that is absolutely right and
something that I support so I would
support the recommendations as laid out
in the report thank you okay don't mean
to cover that area yeah okay so
basically yeah this is the parental
bereavement lis and leave and paid
policy so a new statutory right came in
in April 2020 and this was just give a
bit of context this was further to the
tragic death of a young child about 10
years ago and Jack hurt and his mother
tirelessly campaigned to bring in a law
that would give some provision for leave
away from the workplace with pay when
somebody you know in kind of that
devastating circumstance because there
was nothing before that absolutely
nothing so you know it's right that they
has been put in place and so basically
the statutory right is for up to two
weeks pay leave for employees who have
lost a child under the age of 18 or have
suffered a stillbirth after 24 weeks of
pregnancy so the statutory right is only
based on statutory pay so it would
equate to about a hundred and fifty-one
pounds a week
so the council's made a decision that we
would top that up to full pay so it
basically means if somebody's been in an
awful circumstance they would receive
two week school pay to take some time to
grieve and to you know do what they need
to be do to be with their family and so
basically it's a day one right so
somebody who starts the council next
week if that awful circumstance were to
happen they would have the right in the
entitlement and there's no earnings test
as well because the statutory level of
pay means you've got to meet a certain
level of lower earnings test basically
but we would offer that to everybody
you know that same rights regardless
so basically staffing out circumstance
will access this but it also still be
able to access our current provision
around bereavement leave so currently
there's policy and it's up to three days
paid leave so they'd still be able to
access that as well you know it's
completely understandable that any
member of staff who have encounters that
situation they're just you know not
going to be able to be in work really I
suppose people respond very very
differently some might want some focus
but you know for a large number imagine
it would be the last thing on my mind at
that point of their life and so yes so
that's the policy so we will be getting
that launched but the provision is there
at the moment we would just need to
formalize the policy and do some more
communications on it okay any questions
yes thank you very much indeed thanks
Kate for the it's welcome yes we welcome
the report and dare I say I hope it
never needs - can I just say I also
welcome this and I think it's in that
devastating situation the last thing
people need to be thinking about is is
their wages so I absolutely welcome this
and I'm glad that we're going to be
topping it up to 100% yeah dude just to
echo the comments I think it's a really
good change that has been made and I
think as colleagues have said you know
it's tragic circumstances and I'm really
pleased that we are paying at their
normal rate of pay rather than the
statutory sick pay which is obviously a
lot less than the normal pay so I'm
really pleased about that and I welcome
the reporters whoever said okay I'll
take that one as well
yep so basically reclaiming of
overpayments policy so occasionally
overpayments of salary occur you know we
try to minimize those mostly and they're
quite small amounts and which can
normally be quickly rectified and
resolved like great issue however
occasionally we do have larger amounts
which obviously can be having more of an
impact on staff if it's unexpected and
they've you know got some money they're
going to have to pay back at some point
obviously you know the salaries of our
employees it is public money so we've
always seek to recover
payments and this is confirmed in the
employees contracts of employment the
fact that we you know we would like to
do that we'd you know be expecting that
staff should be regularly checking a pay
slit just to make sure the salary would
seem as they'd expect it and flagging up
any any issues that they're aware of so
we thought it we're good to have a
policy which formalizes what will happen
when an overpayment has been made just
to be clear to staff and transparent
they know what to expect and they know
what the process will be just makes it
much easier for everybody so that's why
we want to implement this policy so
overpayments they tend to occur for a
number of reasons one might be a delay
in information going across to GM SS
from managers or other avenues incorrect
information sometimes might be provided
or they might just be an administrative
error which causes it so as we say
ideally we've want things to be picked
up as quickly as possible so they
escalate and become more of an issue and
if it's only one months of a payment we
normally deduct it straight away the
following month but if it's more than
one month the GM SS service would
normally contact the employee to explain
there's been an overpayment they clearly
state the amount and they did explain
what has happened in a breakdown of the
amount then they would detail a
potential over ABS repayment plan and
normally what tends to be a real of
thumb is you generally repay over the
same number of months as we claim same
number of months as the overpayment has
taken place so it's manageable and fair
to the employee obviously if a member of
staff thinks that's going to be a bit
too difficult for them we'd normally
negotiate and agree something that's
acceptable to them obviously we don't
want anyone to be a financial hardship
through this and that's it really so we
just thought it'd be good to have it all
formalized yeah so any comments or
questions
just to say makes perfect sense to me
anyway and and I support the
recommendations the only query of God is
of the person who would not necessarily
understand that they were being overpaid
if they were new to a salary and we were
overpaying and then next month we take
back the overpayments as well as reduce
their wage to what is going to be to a
certain extent they're taking a double
whammy because the wage itself is going
down as well as the recovery I'm just
wondering circumstances where we would
allow a longer period to take it back if
it was if it was just we put them on a
stage yeah I think I think you know we
can have the general approach of the 80
20 percent the general approach that we
like to use in the Dority of cases but
if somebody is if somebody's feels that
it's gonna significantly disadvantaged
them and they're really going to
struggle you know we would be open to
discussion around you know what can be
done to transport but you know in the
majority cases it tends to be quite
small amounts but say if it was
significant amount it may be more
difficult for that to be recovered the
following month and you know they would
query that with GM SS and they would
consider that
No right in that case we'll move on to
the item eight which is the recovery one
I have included some slides with the
path for employment committee to by wave
and all states in relation to our plans
around
recovery modernization and work or
reintegration so you will recall back
end of last year we did a significant
piece of work with an organization
called future go to help support orange
because the 21st century provide the
public services and that vision remains
unchanged and however what our response
to caving has done is really helpful
crystallized our news around and the
agenda around digitization and also as
well the benefit of having produced and
code the bill when she will now have
being hugely successful in the last two
to three months the what we don't want
to do with lose sight of the way already
undertaken by future but we also want to
build in that element of how we really
enhance that digital and platform and or
both at work from and hands doctor
around community services support
so we've just undertaken before we can
start age with the support and what they
have been able to glean from that
Stockton is sporting in proposals for
enhanced wave programs to help us shape
our vision to become a 20 base sun-joo
the matter of public services we are in
the process of working through those
recommendations now we give you to help
ensure that some programs change to
everyone with the meeting next month
with an update on those particular
programs and in terms of our recovery
strategy
well I've mentioned previously we
consented interview strategy in Leitrim
to impact effects in equality and so
that we truly understand the impact of
coded across the piece right across the
community with laws in Hanford again in
terms of our recovery and we hacked
about that the thesis said an agency
like no other because they are
responding we're also trying to recall
that and and it does make the task at
hand ever so much more complicated and
however will that challenge and one
reactor in that in our recovery strategy
we are likely to manage with some and
some new business as usual will emerge
from from math to give away extreme in
relation to our where clause
reintegration we have set off a subgroup
and that is helping to shape our final
demand we're ordering integration and
code design and that means from the
policy of a but all Nevers well we're
things we've had to save a few in tain
our way from with their teams to shame
that agenda around we're course
reintegration they're key messages at
the moon to our colleagues are continue
to work from here which the producer we
are going to continue to apply the two
meter rule and our buildings will be
occupied proper to 20% and probably
until around September time we intend to
review that over the holidays and we are
in the process of reviewing all policies
around agile flexible working which will
help shape our work orientation homes in
relation to the pauses there about and
what was particular in track we asked
the question of colleagues around and
their approach to ways and come home and
during the big crisis and how they would
like that helped shape the agenda moving
forward and 41 defense bar where both
retained and
if they're they said that they would
like the organization to consider them
waiting from home on a full-time basis
in the aftermath of the crisis and 76
percent of those who retained it to be
significant Norma and stated that they
would like to have some flexibility of
spending some days in the office but
some days at home there has been really
really helpful exercise those two women
to change the activity will continue in
this space and will continue to gather
momentum and hat and an ahead Steve
we are also waiting with the traffic
partnership on our recovery strategy
because actually what has emerged in
terms of how we provide services we can
work with the volunteer sector we can
with our community group and really help
the bicycles our colleagues and we just
won two time fine not now did that help
shape our new strategy for though I'm
happy to take comments on those yeah I
think you know welcome this piece of
work I think clearly we would have
learned a lot of lessons through this
pandemic crisis and new ways of working
that probably would not have happened
have set for this crisis and I think we
have to take you know some of the work
practices that we've learned over this
period and will continue to be learning
you know can be a force for good and I
think you know when we look at remote
working remote meetings
transport all of those things that we
need to considering different in
different ways and you know we've done a
I think a really good job and probably
most councils across the country have
been doing similar well what I would
like to see he is members involvement
because obviously we do have lots and
lots of meetings and they're necessary
meetings to you know to develop you know
the ways forward and policies and etc so
I think I think reading the report there
seems to be a lack of involvement with
with members and and how we're going to
develop in the future so I think I'd
just like to say that you know we could
consider how we might move forward
clearly the work force is critically
important nothing mum and I think you
know maybe some way of you know talking
to our community the in terms of how
they think you know the council's acted
over this period and whether they you
know they can see that some ideas have
have ideas around how we could actually
work so and I think there is another
piece of word that we need to do
alongside or integrated that within the
work that it's being done but I welcome
the me okay yeah can I just come in he's
fun to come fast and leave thank you and
so maybe I should have bad air come fast
and then it was remiss of me not to do
so we have been undertaking some initial
consultations with the exact members
around our reintegration and recovery
strategy what we accept the family to be
much broader and we're looking at plan
to do that now what in terms our
interaction with
we are we've actually been progressing
and actually in Latin space and we've
been working with the traffic
partnership to really help shape what
the council's we can do strategy looks
like that how that dovetails with the
borinage recovery strategy and the
individual strategies of the
organizations and that we work with from
that perspective there is a more
scrutiny to Parliament and
forward-thinking government engagements
thank Joe I think we we should minute
that we appreciate that Corbett 19
really is life-changing for everybody
and will be for the foreseeable future
and I know that members will appreciate
that the work which has been introduced
to meet the challenge in an effort to
maintain the services for the people of
Trafford as well as appreciate the
problems as our staff are facing it's a
huge a huge task totally unprecedented
and so I welcome the report and I know
it will be ongoing thank you Sarah did
you say that 41 percent of the people
that completed the survey said that they
would like to continue working from home
that's 41 percent of colleagues said
that they would like to continue to work
from home full-time and seventies think
with the things they were said that they
would like to continue we're through
with a hybrid sometime in the offices in
town at home I'm going to dig down into
that the reasons as to why that many
want to work from home it's it's not a
problem with the
place you're going to find out why we
thought we asked that question and I
think we've got about 700 comments
councillor Thomason that we just weighed
in and people people's responses a very
different that we've got people who and
have found but wearing my balance too
much is yet now that we have that
ability to to manage things from whom
and we have some people who commute
they've got a lengthy commute and how we
may be asked of different reasons but
what we are doing here I mentioned in my
previous slide about each of our
director to be able to give their
individual finding the way you know so
what's important area is the survey is
anonymous
it absolutely is anonymous but what we
can do is we can identify by Directorate
and by save and that will help us
understand if we do have any of those
problems that may be being around the
way in Leeds itself then they will
become identified well then we should be
able to pick things up quickly
Yumi's good night
there we go sorry about that yeah just a
quick one
don't was finished it's really just an
to make sure we monitor the health and
safety of the new way of working really
I mean speaking from limited experience
I know that Sioux meetings I'm more
pressured I think I feel I don't know
it's probably Sarah as a better probably
done more of these and I have by know if
I've done two or three on the trial I'm
pretty sure by the end of it and I think
we just need to keep an eye on those
sorts of new pressures that generated by
news ways of working it's a really good
point pass the course and we and apart
from the pressure of always being
prepared to have a screen right in front
of your face in any event there is
something about the concentration that's
required within a virtual meeting and
and in our recovery plans and in our
where court reintegration plans we will
most certainly be thinking about the
amount of meetings and the length of
meetings and how we can dog lose cause
you're absolutely right in there there's
days where you finished the day and you
feel completely frazzled with it all yes
so yeah it's a good point thank you okay
so for quarter four which is January to
March this year we had a total of six
requests for an extension of stick pay
of those five agreed one wasn't agreed
however it was on the basis that they're
ill health retirement application have
been approved so it wasn't you know
required
and the spread of those across the
different directorates were one in
adults two in children's and one in
governance and communities okay
any questions the amazing
[Music]